it's springtime you're outside more it
is time for sunscreen but stay away from
the chemical sunscreens with ingredients
that can irritate skin cause hormonal
disruption or Worse instead use mineral
sunscreen by Ginger armor which is just
as effective you'll get 15 off with code
Pacman at gingerarmor.com the link is
down below
given what's going on in the news today
it will be a trump heavy program but we
are going to start by talking about Joe
Biden the current president but before I
even get to that I have to make a really
important correction on the show as as
all of you know uh if you've been around
the show for a while I am not working
with a teleprompter Obama's teleprompter
no uh I I am mostly working off of
General notes when I talk and the other
day speaking off the cuff about Bobby
Kennedy Junior's presidential candidacy
I wrongly said I wrongly said that the
children's defense fund is the
anti-vaccine organization he started it
is not the correct organization that
Bobby Kennedy started is the Children's
Health defense children's defense fund
is in no way affiliated
and is not an anti-vaccine organization
I got that wrong
um and I want to correct that I heard
from children's defense fund and I'm
glad to issue that correction today
let's talk about President Joe Biden we
have such an unusual situation happening
in the 2024 presidential race and
particularly within the Republican
primary that Joe Biden really needs to
do only one thing to win in 2024 and
that is to not screw up David screw up
that's not very precise language what I
mean specifically is that Joe Biden
needs to avoid
self-inflicted errors and he will have I
believe a relatively clear path to
re-election in 2024 despite all of the
criticisms I've had of Joe Biden despite
concerns among many about his age if he
can manage not to quote screw up
I believe that he is going to get
reelected now you might be thinking
David that's very obvious that how does
that count as any kind of political
analysis at this point in time of course
he shouldn't mess up but let me explain
why this is so crucial in this
particular situation first of all what
about problems that aren't Joe Biden's
doing without ignoring the human tragedy
of crises we know from looking at
history that often major crisis events
like 9 11 help the president in power to
the extent that George W bush did not
heed warnings about 9 11 like we can
talk about to what degree 911 could be
blamed on Bush to some degree that's not
what I'm trying to do today but the
point is after 9 11 the country rallied
around Bush and he had a record high
approval before invading the quote wrong
country and squandering the approval so
Joe Biden doesn't have have to worry
from a political perspective
about tragic events Beyond his control
he should of course work to prevent any
tragedy that that is preventable without
a doubt but we're speaking politically
here so then you get to the Republican
Party Biden doesn't have to be amazing
to win in 2024 he has to be better than
the Alternatives he has to be more
stable than the Alternatives and the
alternatives are as much of a mess as I
have ever seen the Republican party is
in disarray there is no coherent Vision
there is no coherent agenda you have a
party divided between do we want more
Trump as the magedonians or magats do
or do we realize that Trump has been a
disaster in 2018 in 2020 in 2022 and we
have to go a different way either way
you have a Republican party that mostly
exists publicly to oppose what Biden
does and say it's all terrible and do
anti-woke culture War nonsense many
still loyal to Donald Trump now under
two indictments for classified documents
federally and then the hush money
situation in New York possibly more
forthcoming indictments and then he's
running again despite the fact that he
is not particularly popular nationally
he is still extraordinarily popular as
the cult leader that he has become among
the Maga people he's actively trying to
sabotage any potential Rivals and in the
meantime you actually have a pretty
solid Republican candidate by the old
standards of the party in Chris Christie
who is polling at last check
uh Chris Christie is polling
uh where is he 1.2 percent his big
announcement last week got him from one
percent to 1.2 percent so Biden can win
simply by not messing up the economy has
to be okay and it is people have to
believe that but the economy has to be
okay and it is
um he has to be decent he has to be uh
stable and that's basically what we need
from Biden in order to see him win and
if you look at recent highly rated
general election polls nationally you
see morning consult from a few days ago
you see Biden's leading DeSantis by
three and Biden's leading Trump by two
these are not blowout numbers at this
point in time but it is really important
to understand that what's going on in
the Republican primary made to swayed
turnout in a way that is not reflected
in the polls and the presence of trump
as the nominee who seems like a shoe-in
at this point although we'll see what
happens okay I'm keeping an open mind at
this point Trump seems like a shoe-in if
Trump is the nominee there is an
intangible group of people that will
come out and say I'm not that engaged in
politics but we can't have Trump back
again and that that is not reflected in
the polls either so my sense right now
is that Joe Biden if he doesn't get in
his own way has a relatively
unobstructed path to re-election whether
I love Joe Biden as a candidate is
irrelevant you all know that I would
like to see a different candidate uh if
it was up to me but I am also going to
give you analysis that is based on what
we have and there is no indication I
mean I don't want to be dark but unless
Joe Biden dies he's going to be the
Democratic nominee I want debates I want
candidates I would love the DNC to hold
debates they're not going to it's not up
to me I can't do anything to change that
uh that is my sense of this race right
now
and over the next 48 hours we will see
Donald Trump go to Miami get arrested
booked arraigned once again he will then
speak from Bedminster tomorrow night
we're going to cover all of it and we
are going to see how do the other
Republican candidates react to that how
does Joe Biden react I assume Joe Biden
will continue saying absolutely nothing
about it which I like I like that Biden
is saying I don't have anything to do
with this independent prosecutors and
investigators are doing what they think
they need to do based on the evidence I
like Biden staying out of it and
governing that is the starkest and most
productive contrast that Joe Biden can
provide at this point in time don't
screw up
could always say that that's what they
need to do but it is so uh particularly
important right now let me know your
thoughts let me know if you agree with
this assessment
Donald Trump is getting indicted on 37
counts and he is facing a hypothetical
536 years in prison and some of his
lawyers have quit I am now going to
catch you up on what is going on with
Donald Trump we had some of the
information last week we now have more
Trump charged with 37 counts in
classified documents case indictment
says among other allegations the
indictment says Trump showed classified
documents to other people in the summer
of 2021 after leaving office the
indictment was made public a day after
the grand jury charged Trump two of
Trump's lawyers resigned from
representing him in the classified
documents case and in another pending
Federal criminal investigation into his
efforts to overturn the loss in 2020.
mediaite reporting Trump maximum
sentences add up to a staggering 536
years in prison for all counts I tell
you this not to trick you into thinking
Trump might end up spending this much
time in prison or any time in prison at
all I still believe the most likely
outcome at greater than fifty percent
odds is that Trump will spend no time in
prison I tell you this to tell you the
severity of the totality of what Donald
Trump has been charged with so I want to
talk about a few different things here
I'm not going to do a deep dive legal
analysis because I'm not a lawyer and
there are many lawyers who can do the
Deep dive legal analysis I'm going to
give you an analysis of the politics
that is surrounding what is going on
here number one there are so many of you
who have written to me and have said
David sir some less politely but many of
you uh referring to me as Sir saying
um this is it right the trumpists now
are going to abandon Trump and the
answer is absolutely not Luke Luke the
bee's knees Beasley is going to be on
the ground for us tomorrow in Miami
interviewing Trump supporters and you
are going to see not only are they not
abandoning Trump they are flocking to
his defense the one remaining analysis
that is valid for what we are now seeing
the defenses of trump from the
magicalists is the cult analysis three
books which I recommended on my live
stream over the weekend if you want to
understand what is going on with
trumpists are three books by the great
non-fiction author Jeff Quinn Jeff Quinn
wrote a book about Charles Manson the
leader of the family who died in prison
some years ago he wrote Jeff Gwen wrote
a book about Jim Jones The Cult leader
of the people's Temple the that was the
murder suicide involving the quote
Kool-Aid that so many people have heard
of and then David koresh of the Branch
Davidians in Waco his most recent book
is about that it is impossible as I
recently read Waco and have previously
read the other books it is impossible to
read those books and not see trumpism in
the descriptions of the cultists and the
cult loyalty that we see or we saw to
koresh Jones and Manson that is the most
important analysis as far as what we
were seeing from the Trump supporters so
then let's continue
um you are going to hear
defenses of trump from cultists but also
from Republican hacks who do this for a
living you are going to hear all sorts
of claims about how this isn't really
that serious and there's really nothing
here and what about Hillary and what
about Hunter Etc the Brazen nature of
that which Trump is accused of credibly
we see evidence in the indictment Trump
not cooperating on the classified
documents moving documents around
seemingly to evade law enforcement
spending months refusing to turn
documents over we found that the
surveillance room
uh was flooded by a Mar-A-Lago employee
when they drained a pool into the
surveillance room although they say that
was not deliberate but it is
extraordinarily suspicious retention of
classified documents showing people
classified documents who don't have
proper security clearances Trump has
lied about every aspect of this he said
oh I Declassified everything
telepathically or whatever but there are
recordings of trump saying I can't show
you these documents because they're
classified meaning he knew that he
didn't actually declassify them so there
are many charges under the Espionage
Etc and we will leave it to the legal
experts to give you the bottom line on
that you can make the argument and I
would defend the argument that we have a
problem in the United States with over
classification of documents we've talked
about it before that's not an argument
I'm afraid of but we're talking about
very serious stuff right here documents
related to military capabilities weapons
capabilities about the Us and other
countries it if Obama had done this they
would be saying it's treason and it
should be the death penalty do not be
confused for even a moment we don't know
what Trump's motive was we just don't
know at this time why was he keeping
these documents one of the things we do
know based on the pictures that have
been released is that Donald Trump was
keeping these documents in boxes in his
bathroom by the way the bad is I've told
you before money can't buy class
um Trump's bathroom for Rich guys just
it's all it's all crazy okay it's every
detail of this is insane but he had
documents in the bathroom he had
documents in his bedroom it's all
completely whacked another defense that
you're hearing is that these are
technical crimes process crimes Trump
hasn't been given due process but the
very same people saying that were
demanding Hillary Clinton be jailed
absent any evidence of criminality
absent an indictment absent an
adjudication a conviction and a
sentencing they were saying just Do not
pass go do not collect 200 go straight
to prison the very same people saying
I'm for Law and Order
we're saying that or said lock up Joe
Biden or whatever and you've got
pictures of Trump's bathroom stuffed
with boxes we have recorded
conversations they want Hunter Biden
jailed and yet we have nothing on Hunter
Biden that is even close to what this
indictment reveals they have on Trump so
you're going to see those people
uh and those very same people making
these defenses might show up tomorrow to
Riot outside the Miami Courthouse I hope
that that doesn't happen but Trump and
others have been uh
inside you know I guess there's really
no other word other than they've been
inciting individuals to go to Miami
tomorrow we saw Mark Levin's delusional
rant on Fox News saying how how dare
they indignant how their how dare they
do this to Trump and it's really
important to remember that not only are
these serious charges and not only do
they seem to have Trump dead to rights
pictures audio recordings all of it one
of the other important things to think
about when it comes to this situation uh
is that this actually shows us we might
have accountability in a justice system
that does have two tiers the two tiers
aren't Democrats and Republicans
Republicans are now saying this it's a
two-tier justice system where if you're
a trump supporter there's different
rules no the two-tier justice system
we've had in this country for a long
time is everybody else and then the
wealthy and the elite who get the best
most expensive lawyers they uh don't
have pre-trial detention either because
it's not assigned or because they can
bail out or whatever that the two-tier
justice system has been that and what we
are to take away from Trump getting
indicted is that no one is above the law
Trump and others keep saying if they can
do this to me they're going to do it to
you
they're already doing it to the
proverbial you we know that the question
was can even someone in a position like
president be held accountable and at
least as far as the indictment goes the
answer might be yes we're going to talk
about Judge Eileen Cannon after the
break and that's going to concern Us in
in some ways last thing and I talked
about this on my stream you might be
wondering am I going to demand Trump's
imprisonment for life or something you
you might notice that in in the story so
far I haven't said Trump should be in
prison or Trump should be in prison for
X Y or Z amount of time because that's
not due process all I want is due
process okay we had enough evidence to
go to a grand jury the grand jury said
that said there is enough evidence to
indict so we've gotten an indictment so
I'm not around here saying oh imprison
Trump for Life what I want is now that
there has been an indictment let's
adjudicate it and depending on its
adjudication either via a plea deal or a
guilty plea a guilty verdict rather then
we can figure out what would be
appropriate sentencing and then let's
talk about a sentence I actually support
law and order I actually support due
process I'm not going around demanding
people be imprisoned because I don't
like their politics I don't like Trump's
politics but what I want
is the same thing that I want for Hunter
Biden if you believe he committed crimes
for Hillary Clinton or whatever the case
may be later in the program we will talk
about the difference between the Trump
classified documents indictment and what
they wanted Hillary locked up for and if
you come with an open mind I can only
imagine you will come away realizing
there is almost no comparison between
the two make sure you're subscribed to
the YouTube channel at youtube.com the
davidpackman show it is a massive
program today long and wide that I can
assure you
it is Springtime it's getting warm we
are all spending more time outside many
sunscreens contain elements that the FDA
has warned about oxybenzone Ava benzone
homo sailate and others these are
absorbed into your bloodstream they can
irritate sensitive skin they can be
hormone disruptors I just stay away from
them and I use mineral sunscreens I do
the same when I put sunscreen on my baby
daughter and our sponsor Ginger armor
makes the world's thinnest 100 mineral
sunscreen it works for all skin types
not just gingers as the name might
suggest it rubs in clear on all skin
tones feels like nothing is on with SPF
50 plus protection Ginger armor also
acts as a plant-based moisturizer with
21 simple gentle ingredients from plants
and minerals it's good for you it's good
for the planet it's more affordable than
other sunscreens with similar quality
ingredients I also love that it's a
small business made in the U.S and they
donate one percent of all sales to the
one percent for the planet charity go to
gingerarmor.com use code Pacman for 15
off the link is down below
so many of you wrote to me over the
weekend and said David can it be can it
really be that a trump-appointed judge
is going to be involved in overseeing
Trump's own indictment tell me it's not
going to happen because that seems so
biased and disastrous well it is part of
the story and I want to talk about it
with you today the New York Times
reports a trump appointed judge who
showed him favor gets the documents case
a surprise assignment of Judge Eileen
Cannon could be a setback for
prosecutors as they unveiled a sweeping
classified files indictment
uh judge Canon 42 a trump appointee
shocked legal experts across ideological
lines last year by intervening in the
investigation and issuing rulings
favorable to Mr Trump only to be rebuked
by a conservative appeals court the
chief Clerk of the courts in Florida
Southern District has said that the that
new cases there are randomly delegated
to its judges even if they are related
to previous ones it was not immediately
clear whether Mr Trump lucked out or if
an exception was made either way legal
Specialists said judge Cannon's return
was significant was significant for
those asking the question slate has a
very good piece by Mark Joseph Stern
judge Eileen Cannon can absolutely sink
the federal prosecution of trump and
this uh reads the federal criminal case
against Donald Trump from his handling
classified documents will be overseen at
least the ninja initially by judge
Eileen Cannon this is excellent news for
Trump and exceedingly bad news for
special counsel Jack Smith
Canon's total lack of discipline
combined with her evident incapacity to
experience shame renders her a uniquely
favorable jurist for the former
president indeed if she maintains her
grasp on this case it is nearly
impossible to Envision Smith securing a
conviction in her courtroom this is of
course the opinion the opinion of Mark
Joseph Stern
this command marked the first time in
history in the history of the Republic
that her federal judge had claimed the
power to stop a pre-indictment criminal
investigation into a suspect Canon's
previous overreach provoked genuine
shock and legal circles and fear in the
intelligence Community as it effectively
blocked officials from assessing the
seized documents for National Security
risks but Canon wasn't finished she
agreed to Trump's request for a special
master and appointed Raymond Deary a
well-respected federal judge after Deery
tried to bring some discipline to the
case Canon immediately ran interference
for Trump overruling an order that would
have required the former president to
either disavow or stand by previous
claims that FBI agents were planted at
Mar-A-Lago and this goes on and on and
on and Mark Joseph Stern then gets to
the critical part
imagine that Canon does preside over
this case
she has infinite tools at her disposal
to thwart the prosecution at nearly
every turn big swings like tossing out
the whole case very real possibility in
her courtroom of chaos can be appealed
and overturned but at every step there
are opportunities for sabotage Cannon
can try to rig War Dyer to help the
defense stack the jury with Trump
supporters she can exclude evidence and
testimony that's especially damning to
Trump she can disqualify Witnesses who
are favorable to the prosecution she can
sustain the defense's frivolous
objections and overrule the
prosecution's meritorious ones she can
direct a verdict of acquittal to render
the jury Superfluous she can declare a
mistrial prematurely for any number of
reasons okay I think you get it so the
backstop here and a couple of lawyers
wrote to me and said you know David
everything that's being written about
what Eileen Cannon can do
is true it's not wrong but it ignores
that there are checks and balances from
other judges that the prosecution could
recur to if necessary and it is not as
scary as some of these articles are
making it out to be it's still scary
but just not quite as scary as some
articles are making it out to be we're
going to be following the Eileen Cannon
sort of narrative and story because it
is actually a potentially huge part of
this prosecution uh maybe tomorrow
probably more after the arraignment on
Wednesday we will get back to this
Donald Trump did not stay home over the
weekend and he gave what I can remember
as the most deflated low energy speech
of his political career Donald Trump
actually gave two speeches over the
weekend he went to Georgia and spoke to
the Republican convention there and then
he flew to North Carolina and spoke to
the Republican convention there I have
never seen Trump like this before
completely deflated
um
I'm just going to play some clips for
you these are only from his North
Carolina speech
um that the Georgia speech was less
remarkable in in a sense so we will just
give you a sense of what was discussed
and even the crowd like not really big
other than when Trump said
anti-transgender stuff which we will get
to here is Donald Trump just sort of
ranting about how we went to UPenn and
saying look they indicted me they
indicted me they're thinking I was a
very good student at the Wharton School
of Finance can you imagine I wonder if
they're proud of me I got indicted I
wonder if they're saying oh that's
wonderful I've been indicted twice now
in a couple of months
you know when I was studying and when I
was uh a very very successful
businessman then I did The Apprentice
and I did lots of books that were big
big big big big sellers yeah even now I
have books that are tremendous sellers I
never had
I never had this stuff in mind I never
had the word indictment
what's indictment mean sure that's when
you're extremely dishonest sir
so as you can see
blabbering and blathering aimlessly and
it only got worse Trump talking about
Ron DeSantis criticizing him and I guess
the crowd sort of like this I don't know
if I weren't leading
we wouldn't be talking about it but
we're leading by a lot we're leading to
sanctimonious by Massive numbers he's
he's heading south quickly no
personality you're gonna have a
personality to win
he's got no personality
yeah and you know remember I mean even
Trump's heart doesn't really seem in
this ridiculous speech and I'll tell you
if I was under the indictments that
Trump is under
I wouldn't be able to go out there and
give nice speeches and be upbeat I like
I actually get it I actually get it but
this is important in order to understand
that the things Trump's saying about oh
this is going nowhere and there's
nothing here this is very serious stuff
uh and Donald Trump knows it on some
level Trump's same saying that now it's
actually hard to say DeSantis because
he's gotten so used to using the
nicknames for DeSantis 56 that means
we're leading Ronda sanctimonious by
56 69 percent for Trump 13 for just
Sanctus
and Pence Essex you know once you get
used to saying to Sanctus it's hard to
say to Santa's I was actually being
interviewed I was trying to be serious
and I called them the Sanctus I said
that's not good but he's changing his
name you know now it's D santis
and I put a little message out never
change your name in the middle of a
campaign
I have to admit that actually is funny
it seems one of the stupidest things you
can do if you're trying to get name
recognition is pronounce your name two
different ways DeSantis and D santis
Trump trump actually in the midst of all
the legal chaos able to put together a
little kernel of good political advice
Donald Trump then seemingly unable to
stop talking about massive dumps I know
guys it's it's hard to believe he's at
it again with the dumps but we can stop
them cold and we will and we would have
had him stop cold and they know that and
they cheated like dogs they cheated like
nobody's ever cheated like a dog or you
turn on your television at 10 o'clock
you would have said Pennsylvania is a
lock
we were up by so much a lock all of a
sudden you see that big fat dump that
big dump at 302 or whatever it was in
the morning it's a disgrace what
happened
uh beautifully put right I mean truly a
Wordsmith uh
it's it's beyond parody Trump then
talking about how there is a taint in
New England
it's a it's a taint such a big big
business such a powerful business and
such an important business New England
as a liberal tent but we're taint I
would say taint is a better word right
but it it's a little bit on the liberal
side they say
such a big big business such a powerful
business and such an important business
uh okay Trump talking about the CNN town
hall and this was building to the
highest energy moment of the night which
of course was an anti-trans moment like
it's almost like you're not gonna get
the crowd riled up about tax policy
you're not going to get the the crowd
riled up about getting people health
care or dealing with the environment
you're going to get people riled up with
anti-trans stuff but in the midst of
that Trump commenting on the CNN Town
Hall New England
sorry what this is the wrong clip here
is the correct clip did you see the town
hall with CNN
they got one of the highest ratings
they've had in like 11 years and they
end up firing the guy because it was
Trump
and said they should celebrate we had
our highest ratings you're supposed to
get paid for high ratings Richard
but then one of the highest ratings
they've had in many many years I was on
with a young woman who was I said nasty
she was a very nasty woman but it worked
out very well and they were all going he
owns you he
screaming AOC is screaming he owns you
get him off the air stop it stop it
but you think if they had high ratings
that would be a big he should ask for an
increase instead they fired him because
I was allowed to put across our point of
view it's hour there you go and now you
can see a guy using his smartphone to
film Trump's entire speech just it's all
so depressing here's the highest energy
moment and this won't surprise you
Trump's highest energy moment was when
he talked about anti-tran stuff and he
even acknowledges wow people really like
hearing this nonsense in critical race
Theory transgender insanity
and other inappropriate racial sexual or
political content of our children
Standing Ovation there
[Applause]
it's amazing how strongly people feel
about that you see I'm talking about
cutting taxes people go like that
talking about talk about transgender
everyone goes crazy that is incredible I
would have thought five years ago you
didn't know what the hell it was
that is an unbelievable statement Trump
is really summarizing in that statement
the absurdity of his own movement they
don't care about actual policy they care
about trans culture War anti-woke
nonsense this is a revelation
about what is animating the right today
Trump says I talk about taxes people
barely clap I talk about the trans stuff
and people go absolutely crazy this is
the monster they built and the question
now is whether this is a monster that
can get them a president in the Oval
Office I hope and to some degree believe
that the answer is no all of these clips
will be available on all of our various
platforms YouTube Facebook Instagram
Tick Tock Etc make sure you're following
us wherever you like to consume your
video content we're going to take a
quick break and then continue our
coverage of this completely absurd
farcical weekend in American politics
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
okay let's look at a couple of other
things from over the weekend uh after or
before or in the middle of Donald
Trump's various speeches to the Georgia
Republican convention and the North
Carolina Republican convention he went
to restaurants at one point he went to a
waffle restaurant and I understand these
sort of photo op things DeSantis did it
in a New Hampshire Diner this is sort of
like what you do in American politics
Trump does it in the weirdest way where
he walks into a waffle spot in Georgia
and starts yelling that we did nothing
wrong and it's I usually when you go to
the restaurants and you do this stuff
you just maybe order some waffles or
something look at the cringe-worthy
nature of what he'll go in and just rant
to Waffle employees about I did nothing
wrong it's the strangest stuff look at
this
foreign
nothing wrong whatsoever we did
absolutely nothing wrong take a look at
the presidential records act we did it
by the book perfect except we have Thugs
and creeps running this country right
it's a real problem for our country
we're going to straighten it away we're
going to win the election big and we're
going to clean up the mess so we're
going to clean up the cancer because
that's what we have
a very strong somebody in the back is
like uh does this mean it's gonna take a
while to get my maple syrup
um what a strange I mean there's a level
of pomposity with just going through a
place where people are having breakfast
and starting to rant and Rave about you
did nothing wrong I did nothing wrong
here's another video and again I don't
know if this is all the same restaurant
it seems he may have gone to different
restaurants in this one it sounds like
someone was trying to pray for Trump
this is serious cult stuff very very
serious cold stuff and I don't know how
the people in the restaurant are
embarrassed for each other at the end of
the day
our country is going to hell we're not
gonna let it happen
oh my goodness so in this one there's a
crowd around Trump a woman on either
standing on a table or piggyback yells
something about this is the only my only
President and then Trump says the
country is going to hell the cut it
seems almost like a place you would you
would sooner guess that this was a bar
full of drunk people at 1am rather than
a Waffle House or waffle restaurant
um with a with a failed former president
then this is maybe the most telling
trumpian moment a woman comes up to
Trump to talk to Trump about sergeant
major Pat Payne
sergeant major Pat Payne is someone that
Trump awarded a medal of honor to in
2020 because Pat Payne was involved in
freeing 75 Isis held hostages okay
that's a fine totally reasonable thing
Trump seems visibly confused and asks
asks if Pat Payne died from war injuries
it's like no dude after he came back
from releasing the 75 hostages you gave
him the Medal of Honor and Trump seemed
so confused that he ends up asking if
the woman could maybe draw Trump with
muscles it's it's beyond parody I am a
medal of honor a portrait artist this is
Sergeant Major
word of the medal of on
and this is actually his thing you can
tell from Trump's nodding that he has
not even the slightest recollection of
this
[Music]
absolutely
no he's actually currently still alive
did he pass away no no no He's Alive
um he is an early active duty he's about
um I think he's in his in his 40s
he's still
you understand what's happening right
Trump has quite literally no idea who
she's talking about who's who the
picture is of no memory injured he's
acting like this is some old war veteran
or someone kill the freed 75 hostages
and then you gave him the Medal of Honor
that's unusual yeah
right beautiful job thank you so much
Trump seemingly confusing the Purple
Heart with the Medal of Honor I mean I
don't know thank you I want to look like
that guy so Trump wants the muscles of
but completely I know this is a
kafka-esque moment I'm sorry folks I
have to say it is a kafka-esque moment
and then lastly
um here again just people screaming and
it's all it's all a big to do
look we have to fake dude idiot
I like the Hat he did a good job before
with the pictures
thank you everybody for coming it's a
nice crowd
this year
okay the waffles are good and Trump's
gonna try one so uh almost worse than
the Ron DeSantis Diner visit in New
Hampshire a couple of weeks ago Trump
twice indicted in the midst of low
energy confused speeches where he tells
corrosive lies and says things that are
untrue uh showing up at a waffle
restaurant and making a complete and
total fool of himself all right now with
that out of the way let's get to
something serious uh William Barr was
Donald Trump's Attorney General
and William Barr I do not consider a
friend of the Progressive Movement
William Barr is not someone I would even
remotely consider for attorney general
but William Barr does have some legal
expertise there is no question about
that and William Barr went on Fox News
Sunday and said that if half of the new
Federal indictment Federal indictment
against Trump is true
Trump is toast this is super interesting
stuff it wildly triggered Donald Trump
let's listen to what Barr had to say and
he's making a lot of sense here have you
um what about this this Chief argument
that comes up for the president's allies
and his legal team that this should have
been handled under the presidential
records act not this espion act
Espionage Act charge in other Federal
statutes that were used here
well it started out under the
presidential records act and and the
archives trying to retrieve documents
that Trump had no right to have but it
quickly became clear that what the
government was really worried about were
these classified and very sensitive
documents I was shocked by the degree of
sensitivity of these documents and how
many there were frankly
and so the government's agenda was to
get those uh protect those documents and
get them out and I think it was
perfectly appropriate to do that it was
the right thing to do and I think the
counts under the Espionage Act that he
willfully retained those documents or
solid counts now I I do think we have to
wait and see what the defense says and
and what proves to be true but I do
think that even half what Andy McCarthy
said which is if even half of it is true
then he's toast I mean it's a it's a
pretty it's a very detailed indictment
and it's very very damning okay that is
an extraordinary statement and it also
sort of uh deals with one of the claims
that so-called legal experts like Mark
Levin are making which is that this
stuff isn't even really related to the
criminal world of law that this is all
just presidential records act subject to
that and William Barr says sure
initially it was subject to that but
between based on the evidence in the
indictment which includes alleged
obstruction and it includes all of these
other things that Trump is accused of
doing it becomes criminal and that's
that's it it's short you can say until
you're you're blue in the face this is
presidential record stuff it went
criminal when Trump covered it up tried
to keep the documents potentially tried
to destroy documents etc etc uh and that
is absolutely very very serious stuff
then we go to Fox news's favorite legal
commentator Jonathan Turley Jonathan
Turley has been defending Trump
reflexively for years now on so many
different issues even Jonathan Turley
says this is a very damning indictment
listen to this president gozad to say
well what if we what happens if we just
don't respond at all to The subpoena I
guess or don't play ball with them the
president goes on to say wouldn't it be
better if we just told them we don't
have anything here well look isn't it
better if there are no documents uh you
know they they've got these
conversations that were memorialized by
the president's attorneys there's also
this recording of him where he talks
about this plan that's believed an
attack plan against Iran I mean they've
got a lot of information in this
Jonathan
no it is an extremely damning indictment
uh you know there are indictments that
are sometimes called narrative or
speaking indictments these are
indictments uh that are really meant to
uh make a point as to the depth of the
evidence there are some indictments that
are just Bare Bones this is not uh the
special counsel uh knew that there would
be a lot of people who were going to
allege uh that the Department of Justice
was acting in a biased or politically
motivated way this is clearly an
indictment uh that was drafted to answer
those questions it's overwhelming and
detailed and you know the Trump team
should not fool itself these are hits
below the water line uh these are
witnesses who apparently testified under
oath gave statements to Federal
investigators both of which can be
criminally charged if they're false
those Witnesses are directly quoting the
president uh in encouraging others not
to look for documents or allegedly to
conceal them it's damaging and the key
here to keep in mind is that every case
I've ever been involved with the
indictment was a Heart Stopper you know
these are written by lawyers who are
trying to convict a client every
indictment I've ever dealt with has
fallen apart to some degree once we look
more carefully at what the evidence may
be but this is is not a an indictment
that you can dismiss all right so there
is Jonathan Turley even with his Heming
and hawing saying this is very serious
stuff back to William Barr William Barr
putting the blame for all of this
squarely on Trump and that's where it
should be so and we can't forget here
that this entire thing came about
because of Reckless conduct of the
president if he had just turned over the
documents which I think every other
person in the country would have done
the government's documents their
official records they're not his
personal records battle plans for an
attack on another country or or defense
department documents about our
capabilities are in no Universe Donald J
Trump's personal documents and then
lastly from William Barr
Trump's claims that other presidents did
the same thing Barr debunks it good for
him to his credit he is undoing every
single one of these Trump arguments the
sock drawer case with President Clinton
he'll point to these and say listen
they're two big lies I think that are
out there right now one is oh these
other presidents took all these
documents those were situations where
they arranged with the archives to set
up special space under the management
control and security provided by the
archivist to temporarily put documents
until the libraries were ready because
we're not people just putting them in
their basement okay and the second thing
that the president this idea that that
that the president has complete
authority to declare any document
personal is obvious it's facially
ridiculous that opinion had to do with
the distinction between official records
which are records prepared by government
agencies for the purpose of government
action
and personal documents as opposed to
official documents which are things
prepared by the president such as a
diary or notes which are not used in the
government's deliberations and yes as to
the second class stuff that the
president himself generates the
president has some discretion but these
are official documents it's an arguable
yep listen
um William Barr you don't have to like
them to recognize that he is on much
stronger legal footing here than a
random Fox news commentator indignantly
saying there's nothing here William Barr
is right and that's why it's so
triggered Donald Trump when he said this
let's talk about that briefly next
Donald Trump exploded on his own former
Attorney General William Barr calling
him a gutless pig because William Barr
gave a sober and sensible legal analysis
which indicated the indictment against
Trump is very serious Trump's early
argument about how other presidents did
the same thing aren't very good and that
Trump is toast if even half of the
indictment is accurate in response
Donald Trump losing his mind on Troth
Central posting quote virtually everyone
is saying that the capital I indictment
is about election interference and
should not have been brought
except Bill Barr a disgruntled former
employee and lazy attorney general who
was weak and totally ineffective he
doesn't mean what he's saying it's just
misinformation bars doing it because he
hates Trump for firing him he was
deathly afraid of the radical left when
they said they would impeach him he
knows the indictment is bull turn off
Fox News when that gutless pig is on and
again
when you listen to what William Barr
says and then you see that Trump rebuts
none of the actual legal claims and
Trump is not a lawyer and Trump has no
idea what's being said
in this particular case doesn't mean you
have to like either of them I believe
Willian Bart William Barr's analysis
comes much closer to getting to the
heart of this indictment than does
trumps which is it was election
interference and I did nothing wrong
after the break we will look at Lindsey
Graham subjected to just very light
questioning about these issues wild wild
stuff quick break and back with that
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show Republican
senator Lindsey Graham has occasionally
been one of the strongest and most
unhinged Defenders of President Donald
Trump in the past sometimes screaming
sometimes crying and becoming indignant
sometimes saying you've just got to send
Trump money and maybe me as well well
Lindsey Graham appeared yesterday on
ABC's This Week With George
Stephanopoulos and it is an absolute
Delight to see but also disturbing
because we know many of the Maga people
are going to buy these arguments on
multiple occasions George Stephanopoulos
attempted to get Lindsey Graham to
answer really simple questions about
Trump and Lindsey Graham went all but
her emails quite literally talking about
Hillary Clinton let's look at the first
clip here is a very simple question do
you stand by Trump did nothing wrong
Donald Trump said repeatedly repeatedly
that he did nothing wrong do you believe
that
well here's what I believe we live in an
America where if you're the Democratic
candidate for president Hillary Clinton
Secretary of State you can set up a
private server in your basement to
conduct government business and when an
investigation has had about your
activity no let me finish oh but you
didn't answer the question that was
ridiculous well yeah I'm trying to
answer the question from a republican
point of view that may not be acceptable
on this show well it's not an answer
right
do you see do you agree Trump did
nothing wrong
Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton Hillary
Clinton wait I'd like you to answer the
I am answering the question from a
republican point of view whoa okay okay
uh George Stephanopoulos tried again and
said there are audio recordings here
there are audio recordings and Lindsay
figures out a way again to talk about
Hillary Clinton there is an audio tape
of Donald Trump saying he knows this is
secret information he knows he's sharing
with other people how is that okay
it's I'm not saying it's okay I'm not
saying it's okay to take a hammer to uh
a Blackberry I don't think I think none
of this is okay
so then referring again to Hillary
Clinton uh you know acid washing hard
drives and taking hammers to
blackberries or whatever it was she was
accused of so a couple different things
here first of all it is not a defense
I'm going to deal with the Hillary
Clinton allegations specifically even
though I know it's like we're a decade
late on the whole thing and he's still
talking about it but give me a moment to
lay this all out
it is not a defense to say
because other prosecutors in other
matters at other times made different
charging decisions after other
investigations related to other possible
charges
that has nothing to do with Trump and
it's sort of like if I was arrested for
whatever right if I would if I was
arrested for attempted murder and then I
say someone else 10 years ago in a
different state was investigated under
different circumstances for attempted
murder and they weren't charged that
doesn't mean anything that's not any
it's not actually a defense
second part of this Hillary Clinton was
accused of being extremely careless in
her handling of classified information
she was not accused of intentionally
disclosing information there is no
evidence she lied to investigators she
cooperated and handed over tens of
thousands of emails etc etc
Trump is accused of willfully risking
National Security secrets and conspiring
with lawyers and others to conceal
documents and make false statements he
did not cooperate with the investigation
he hid the documents for months at his
house in boxes near his toilet Hillary
Clinton was cleared twice by the FBI of
criminal charges so the situations
aren't actually analogous but it doesn't
matter to people like Lindsey Graham
this next segment is going to be the
totality of my coverage of the Turning
Point USA Women's Summit many of you
sent me clips from this Summit Lauren
bobert and others speaking it was a
totally insane event Turning Point USA
is this on-campus right-wing
organization they did an event over the
weekend which was specifically for a
young right-wing women I guess I'm just
going to look at one piece of it with
you so we can say we looked at the sort
of stuff that was going on there I'm
going to play a clip for you where a
woman in the audience tells a story
about trans people in the bathroom with
her and then Marjorie Taylor green goes
transphobic and says listen trans people
in bathrooms they're in there to have
sex with you that's why they're there
did he taken away from me when I found
out that my school had put multiple
biological males in my locker room and
bathrooms some of which will just sit
there and watch me in the other girls
chains okay that's already not okay if
they're they love to pretend they love
to pretend that this is all about trans
people anybody who just hangs out in a
locker room or a bathroom
checking people out can be reported it
doesn't matter what their gender
identity is either way the behavior
isn't allowed which immediately makes me
skeptical about this story we're just
trying to dress in peace and be able to
go to our PE classes
um me and my dad made quite a fuss last
year at my school and in my community
and I have spoken in front of my uh very
woke School Board many times however
nothing seems to happen even though they
are violated thousands of girls every
day
do you have any advice for me as a 16
year old trying to change the mind of
adults and make a difference
thank you
first of all thank you for your courage
right because yep thank you
because when you when you're speaking
out in your school to your school board
you and your father and your family and
you're standing up against men who are
really a bunch of perverts in your
locker room in your bathroom because
they listen
they want to have sex with you that's
why they're in there that's real they're
it's not they're not saying oh I
identify as a woman and I'm only
attracted to men that is a lie these are
sexual predators they're sexual
predators
there are statistically almost zero
incidents of the kind that they would
have you believe are rampant they're it
just it just doesn't happen
okay
this
my advice for for you is your safety is
number one ladies your safety is number
one and and that when you all join
together and make that known and refuse
to accept these this is also disgusting
as I've said before do you really think
that actual violent predators are going
to be dissuaded by the gender sign on
the bathroom door it's absurd and
ridiculous and of course when then you
go further and say Well there must be
hundreds or thousands or at least dozens
of incidents were based on a falsely
stated gender identity someone hid out
in a bathroom and then assault you find
out that it is essentially non-existent
and it is all part of the story that
they use to prop up this anti-trends
anti-trans paranoia that they are now
obsessed with and that they are raising
money around at the end of the day we
have a voicemail number that number is
219 to David P
here's a smart caller this caller thinks
he may know the truth about the latest
Trump indictment listen to this hi David
I think this indictment of trump on
seven plus counts is just a distraction
from Obama Gates I mean there's still so
many
unanswered uh questions uh and and
there's such a mountain of evidence that
right too like why are people focusing
on things like uh sexual assault
sergeant and uh steel and classified
documents when they could be focusing on
Obama gays absolutely
Obama gate is the biggest crime of the
century I don't know of which century
maybe this one maybe last one it's never
really clear Obama gate is
extraordinarily serious I also don't
know what it is and clearly all of this
stuff that's going on you know a jury
finding Trump responsible for sexual
assault and defamation of e Gene Carroll
a 37 count indictment involving pictures
of classified documents around Trump's
toilet like a fort
all of it is a trumped up for lack of a
better term distraction
from Obama gate which they don't want
you to know about all right let me put
my brain back in on the bonus show today
the Supreme Court has unexpectedly
upheld a provision prohibiting racial
gerrymandering some are surprised by it
Unabomber Ted Kaczynski has died in
prison
reportedly by Suicide at age 81 we will
discuss the story and his legacy we will
also talk about the White House being
accused of flag code violations because
of their pride month display this is
getting so pathetic from these folks who
have no issue putting the flag on a
bandana that says Maga and doing the
exact same thing now all of a sudden
they're concerned because of the pride
flag okay all of those stories and more
will be on today's bonus show
which will be the first nation
we are taking the bonus show to Nars and
Beyond you can sign up at joinpakman.com
you can use the coupon code
indicted again that's right indicted
again a self-explanatory coupon code use
it save a bunch of money get the bonus
show we will see you then
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors it's springtime
you're outside more it is time for
sunscreen but stay away from the
chemical sunscreens with ingredients
that can irritate skin cause hormonal
disruption or Worse instead use mineral
sunscreen by Ginger armor which is just
as effective you'll get 15 off with code
Pacman at gingerarmor.com the link is
down below